Yes. She graduated from there. And you had the Catholic school girls. They,
yeah,
they like to hear there's a lot of sexuality that goes on inside Catholic high
schools. Um,
I went to an all boys Catholic high school and we would run and sprint to the
all girl Catholic high school, which was three train stops away.
The Mary Lucy Academy.
I just wait for the girls to come down the Hill and like all my,
like a fall day when the wind would blow,
we would just smell the girls as they walked by and then get back on the train
and jerk off when we were all high school students.
And it got to be such a problem that like,
we would just run like little Malloy rats to go see the Mary Lewis girls that
Mary Lewis actually pushed their dismissal time, uh, earlier. So we,
the girls were out already and we were still in school,
but guys would make up like illnesses or like say that they had to leave a last
period just so they could get on the train and get off at one 79th street and
smell the girls, walk it by creeps.
I think a lot of the religious repression is worth it just for how much of a
sexual freak. It turns you into a freak and it's also just fun and interesting,
you know? Like I just feel like, I just feel like, yeah,
like when you go to a Catholic school,
you just have all these stories that just like, you know, it's just wild.
Like you would only know if you went to Catholic school, but I mean, it's nuts.
Some of it you black out too, so you can't remember those stories, right? Yeah,
yeah, exactly. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. If I could get hypnotized,
I would probably remember the real juice, but really have some good stories.
If we get a guy with a, what a, what a pocket watch in here. Yeah. But she's.
We really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about,
this is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications, get jiggy with it and.
Go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys, where things get really.
Wild.